happy Tuesday reject nation greg alba
coming at you with another trailer for
rampage well this movie looks like a ton
of fun from the first trailer I'm
actually pretty excited to see the
trailer a number two oh and by the way
patron the day shout-out for Cody Bedell
arrest your George he was two years old
was it really good actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no George
[Music]
[Music]
mommy
[Music]
[Music]
of course the wolfes lies
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so I think this trailer is actually
better than the other one the other one
looked cheesy unintentionally funny I
thought it was taking itself pretty
serious the first trailer but then this
one has so much humor throughout its the
interaction of the rocks-- character
with the humans and the gorilla George
there was so much humor there and the
way he was reacting to situations
throughout this entire trailer Dwayne
Johnson shows me that this movie looks
like it's gonna be pretty self-aware of
what it is it looks like the movies
gonna actually not take itself too
seriously and just have a lot of fun
with its concept have a lot of fun with
its script and that's what I wanted it
to be and a lot of ways I'm looking
forward more to this movie than Pacific
Rim uprising the effects on George look
great Dwayne Johnson
I prefer him more when he is doing
something more comedic I prefer more in
this genre than I do in something like a
skyscraper and I felt the tone here
although there were times where I was
like would you really make a joke in
this moment this concept is so
ridiculous that I never mind like when
he's hanging out of the airplane like
where he's hanging out of the plane and
Naomi Harris is saying we're gonna die
he's like probably I don't know if
that's a time for a joke but in his
movie why not who cares and the tone
feels like this will be more entombed
with what the movie actually feels like
like I said the first trailer felt more
self-serious
this one seems to give me a better idea
of the characters and the tone of the
film which is most important to me and
how this film will play out right now it
looks like The Rock's having a lot of
fun the action sequences are like a
total blast you actually get a good
glimpse at Naomi Harris's character who
looks like she'll actually be a
character I think the ending part of the
trailer kind of spoils some stuff the
whole trailer is like George has gone on
a rampage George is bad just like the
rest of these monsters and then you know
it seems like it's an obvious plot term
but I don't know kind of wish I didn't
confirm it in the trailer where George
eventually goes back to being good and
they work side by side with the rock to
take down the other big bad monsters or
whatever I'm not really tuning into this
movie for the plot I just want to check
out the movie for all the fun monster
mayhem I just want to say I know that
they're still prepping and building up
for the Godzilla vs. King Kong movie
this movie should be lucky that it's
come
before that there's really elements of
it we were like a little bit of a
Godzilla versus King Kong wannabe that
would feel really bad if this came out
after Godzilla versus King Kong so the
fat it's coming up before doesn't ruin
that for me and patron the day shout-out
today for Cody Bedell and message him on
patreon because he became a patron
recently my ass and my Long's been
watching the channel 4 cuz I like to get
to know people before I give shout outs
I'm gonna skip through some of this
stuff he said he's a giant movie and TV
nerd he watches a lot of channels with
reviews breakdowns and discussions it
was about two or three months ago when
he found us and ever since then he's
been watching all of our old videos and
the new ones as they're uploaded he
loves how we review and breakdown movies
and TV shows and he thinks for the best
on YouTube at the moment and then I sent
him a question this was almost a whole
week ago and you still haven't gotten
back to me Cody if you think we're the
best if you really do love us why are
you ignoring us I mean you pledged the
patreon so that's cool but come on man
reply back to us when I did a Google
search for what the name cody means I
got a search result saying this an Irish
baby name meaning helpful and you know
what you're not being very helpful right
now I would love it if you could reply
back to us so we could keep a
conversation dynamic going but if you
don't reply back to us can you still say
pledge the patreon that's what matters
most no but no series caridy thanks for
the compliments man hope to hear back
from you soon
all it takes for me to say I love you is
for you to say how much you love us it's
just that simple
so I love you Cody anyway guys you can
subscribe to there anyway guys what'd
you think of the rampage trailer do you
like it more than the first one
I certainly do you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up make sure to check out
our patreon become a patreon a check
today exclusive video reactions to
full-length TV shows and music videos
over there weekly Q&A s go check it out